authorities in California have confirmed
test results of a suspicious package
found near Facebook's main campus were
negative it was feared to contain a
deadly poison Niki Bateses with us with
more on this story because Niki we
understand that Facebook's own
technology originally spotted this
pocket this package rather is a
potential threat true
that's right Gail good morning the
package was found at Facebook's mail
facility outside San Jose in the heart
of Silicon Valley a facebook
spokesperson says the equipment that
tech company uses to screen mail helped
sound the alarm
hazmat crews spent the overnight hours
testing air samples after the presence
of a material suspected to be the nerve
agent sarin was found the package was
retested three times with two positive
and one negative result Facebook
evacuated for buildings yesterday after
the package was found all of those
buildings have since been cleared to
reopen to employees Facebook released a
statement this morning saying our
rigorous security and safety procedures
worked as intended to limit exposure and
keep our people safe the two people that
handled the mail in question have shown
no signs or symptoms and are thought to
have not been exposed Anthony Nikki
thank you